Chuyên ông Công chung có thương báo sẽ không tiến hành cải tạo bởi chức xúc tắm toàn nhà
Thực hô chung cưu, quanh phút khóc, để hư hạnh nặng sau vụ hảng hãng thẳng mềm một năm nay nghiên thương trà mâm
Mà dự kiến chi khoảng tắm trăm bảm vi trở đu lo mĩ để mua lại và phá dỡ thức công trình này
Sau đó, truyền đổi thành công viên họ cơ sở giá hội
Cũng đứa đưa ra với lý xong bảo đảm ảnh toàn lâu dài và hiệu quả khuy hại đủ thiệt
Tuy nhiên, kế hoạch đá phá phá nứng tụng bộ phóng tư dân diện hưởng, châu sàng phân ở mua lại chưa phá nè đủ mó mổ đu cải thiết
Và trở về nơi ở khú, nhiều hộ sân định nghĩ chính quyền xem xét phương ánh tải định cư lâu dài cải chỗ
Thay vì sóa bảo toàn bộ khuy nhà, ở chung lạng một số truy ra người đệnh mức xámu lại đu đề sớt
Là tương đối hảo pháng, thầm chi khá hương mà bằng xấu dịch cân đây, rút các hộ dân có hạn án tìm chủ ở mới
Cái khoả phẩm xác hình này cho thấy đà sống chủ giữ giữ nghiênb về phương ánh ngồi lại, sau vẫn tổng cải tì lệ đáng kể chưa đồng thần, khiến quyết cơ chính chấp pháp li kếm xài vẫn được đặt xa